that's enough force people already have
the aggression from Chicago thank you
very much for coming so early in the
morning come and before I start to
disclaimers about the title slide first
like the title here says monopoly
whatever monopolist we dropped it from
the paper because people did not like it
when we argued that any he thinks that
so she would beat Khan maybe a
monopolist and like just like to be
super clear about this I'm not gonna say
that Bitcoin is gonna be monopolist and
just like if Bitcoin were to be by some
magic a monopolist it won't incur some
of the issues that we have currently
with monopolist and I'll try to convince
you doing this talk that that's why you
should maybe you should care as
economist about Bitcoin that has you to
do new things to address monopoly power
yeah and the second and maybe more
important thing is this is joint work
would go Hoberman and CI Mac more lemme
both from Columbia University and this
actually started cause Ghul was teaching
a class on FinTech and he came into my
office and told me that we should
understand Bitcoin and I should help him
understand it and for some reason it
became my job and we had this paper yeah
so let me start with this motivating
slide okay so this is taken from from a
site called coin market cap which gives
a bunch of data about different
cryptocurrencies okay so I guess you all
heard about cryptocurrencies so I'm
gonna spell words on what bitcoin is and
the two points I want to make on the
slide is one does many variants here
okay so I'm a talk I'm gonna talk about
Bitcoin specifically to be concrete but
a lot of what I'm saying what I'm gonna
talk to you about apply is much more
broadly to all the other
cryptocurrencies and it's a challenge
for all such platforms okay second thing
I want you to take away from this slide
is that there's a lot of those platforms
out there and they're viable so in this
website like one of the statistic they
give is the market cap which is how much
is the total value of outstanding coin
in each one of those systems I'm gonna
ignore that for the entirety of the talk
I'm just going to assume that for some
whatever reason people think that
beacon has value but I'm not gonna talk
about what the value should be a why it
should be valuable then we're gonna take
it it's given instead I'm gonna focus on
this other chart here which is actually
not like the correct statistic here the
volume here includes a bunch of volume
that is traded on exchanges not going
through their systems themselves but the
volume of trade on the systems themself
is pretty high so billions of dollars
transfer I'll transfer it every day on
the Bitcoin system and regardless of
whether you think that this is like just
watch trading or senseless Bitcoin is
doing a good job transferring these
billions of dollars every day so I'm
gonna think of Bitcoin and all those
other systems as systems that allow us
to send valuable considerations maybe
send money in a digital form online and
think about the governance and about the
features and I guess the first thing is
you should think about like sending
money online sounds like a great thing
but we know to do this this is not a new
thing so let's start with like the old
school way of how we do this basically
only you need to be able to transfer
money digitally it's an equivalent of an
Excel spreadsheet so somebody has an
Excel spreadsheet it says like I have
$100 in my account I want a transfer
yash $50 it sharks that I have enough
dollars to transfer to yash and the
transfer is man and you just update the
Excel spreadsheet and there's a bunch of
companies that do those services PayPal
venmo there's a bunch of services Swift
Fedwire Visa or MasterCard like there's
a lot of services out there that allow
you to transfer money digitally does it
work well all those companies hold some
database there is possible for all the
computers involved and they basically do
an elaborate way that is somewhat
equivalent to this Excel spreadsheet to
just updates come users have some app or
some way of dealing with them and
everything works come okay so what's the
problem with this yeah so one straumann
or what I think is a straw man is one
thing is
so a lot of people a lot of the initial
performance of Bitcoin said in order to
use those systems they need to trance
Bank of America venmo all people that
they're not stealing money out of my
account that are not doing any
shenanigans and the reason I say it's a
straw man it's because we have
institutions to deal with it
so if Bank of America would steal money
out of my account we'll we'll catch them
eventually and punish somebody if Wells
Fargo started charging me things that
they shouldn't
well maybe eventually somebody will get
blamed for this and punished
maybe but generally we have institutions
that enable us to trust financial
institutions but few problems that a
one-hour raise and I think that Bitcoin
will be actually useful in addressing
all potentially useful in addressing is
one the monopoly dead were tossed and
second hold up both of those stem up
because payment services are network
business so if all my friends are on
people I'm much more likely to be on
people as well if I have em X and none
of my none of the stores except MX MX is
not valuable to me all right so it's how
to compete in this business there's a
lot of barriers to entry and there's a
lot of pricing power generally for all
those of all those payment systems and
incidentally venmo is owned by people so
films that have pricing power generally
would like to price higher than is
socially efficient and will incur some
monopolies deadweight loss kind of you
can think of credit cards refusing to
process low value transactions by
setting the fees high and trying to
extract more rents you can think of lack
of access like lack of financial access
for the pool like I'm not trying to be
monopoly power all of those things but
like some of those things have been like
coming up in political debates with
something so
let's load them in the second issue is
hold up well those companies may want to
commit to some sort of contract with
with their users but they can't and like
the issue comes up that maybe you'll
offer me free service for a few years
but once you create the network effect
and everybody's locked in you'll start
to ratchet up prices and extract more
rights from the system so I don't want
to get into the system to begin with so
Google Checkout didn't really take off I
think that there was at least impressed
people voiced concern that Google was
offering this great service so free but
people were afraid to take it up because
once everybody's locked into their
system they have a lot of monopoly power
so I think those two things are real
economic concerns for those systems and
of course there's other solutions for us
one of which is regulation for example
regulating interchange fee for debit
cards by Visa and MasterCard but Bitcoin
poses one alternative that will not
suffer from the same problems so how is
between different so let me start by
doing the analogy in two steps
okay so very mind people we can think
about them as the bus company they have
a bunch of servers they own the servers
they're the only one who can provide the
computation and infrastructure in
Bitcoin anybody can provide the
computational infrastructure so they're
like the uber and lyft counterparts to
the bus company so if you want to be
part of the
network of servers that runs the Bitcoin
payment processing network you can just
do that by going back to your office
downloading some code and starting to
run a node and you'll even be painful
for that and given that the assignments
will pay the electricity you may make a
small profit okay so anybody can become
minor that's one of the computers that
run the Bitcoin network as opposed to
like those central
system that are centrally controlled but
there's a step further so if you think
about uber uber sets rightful drivers
decides which drivers are allowed to
participate which are not and can route
drivers and make various other decisions
as well as siphon money out of the
platform in the form of fees in Bitcoin
there's no entity that controls the
platform as well and when I write here a
Bitcoin let me just reiterate the same
thing applies to aetherium and many
other of those decentralized protocols
were you can think of this as sort of a
marketplace which is controlled by
nobody and the rules of the marketplace
are determined by this decentralized
protocol
saying think of this protocol as saying
we made Thursday afternoon in the
markets world to trade our cucumbers and
tomatoes this is a protocol this is the
convention that binds everybody and
you're free to do whatever you want on a
personal machine but if you do something
different you'll just be incompatible
with other devices much like the Wi-Fi
standard so you have a Wi-Fi device it
can talk to other Wi-Fi devices you're
free to write whatever Wi-Fi device you
want but if you change it I keep wanting
to be compatible with other Wi-Fi
devices
same here like you can write whatever
you want but in order to change the
system you need to convince everybody
else and be compatible make a change
that everybody agrees on so for the
purpose of this talk I'm just gonna take
it as a fixed set of rules for the
bigger problem that's immutable so you
can change it like there's some process
of changing but it requires kind of
broad consensus everybody to create a
change okay so with all of that Bitcoin
kind of has a different market structure
it still has costs you still need to pay
for the servers you still need to get
money from the users to decide how the
servers are gonna get funded and that's
gonna be the main part of our analysis
that's what got us started how do you
pay for this and how does the funding
model and the market structure differ
from what you get under film so under
firm the firm has a lot of
discretion it can set the rules it can
decide how much infrastructure to
procure and how much to charge users for
fees yeah what I'm going to show you in
this talk is that the rules that in that
the rules that are built into the
Bitcoin system where the marketplace
well the number of miners is determined
through some entering exit condition and
the total revenue varies by the system
and that the users pay something that
will be an equilibrium congestion
pricing and really importantly the
miners run the system but have no effect
on pricing they cannot profitably raise
all over prices in the system so you get
a very different different set of
properties then you get under the
monopolist rant system come and I think
that's where it's interesting it's a
very different funding and pricing model
okay so I'm not gonna explain Bitcoin
there's a parallel program here on
proofs
consensus and decentralization here you
know in Symonds they have some great
videos online from the bootcamp they
have like a bunch of content here
they'll do much better of explaining
what bitcoin is but let me just like
give you a couple of features that come
up form data centers as algorithm and
the one one small thing I should say is
that this is not exactly the regular
mechanism design exercise cuz there's a
bunch of constraints of to make Bitcoin
work to make Bitcoin secure to make the
Bitcoin decentralized network actually
achieve what it needs to achieve come
I'm gonna abstract away from all of that
and just take the constraints and design
choices that were made in Bitcoin and
kind of translate them into their
marketplace that once done sated why
don't you do things differently well
some things you can change here some
things you can't if you want to talk to
me offline and I think the design here
is gonna be very interesting to I'll say
a bit about it event okay so first thing
I should note in Bitcoin
users get to chase users get to choose
the transaction fees so I have an app
that holds my Bitcoin it looks in many
ways similar to your Bank of America app
or venmo
app and you can use this app to send
money to other people when you send
money you get to choose how much are you
gonna pay for this transaction and this
is a design choice you can think of
other ways of doing this this is this is
something that can be pretty flexibly
changed on the minus sides miners again
are the servers in the system there are
infrastructure providers so the miners
are the full profit they provide some
computational power and they want to
make profit and the system does not have
full power over them the system can
dictate some things of what that allowed
or not allowed to do but in many ways
they have a lot of discretion so one is
a miner actually adds to the ledger and
process the transaction by think of it
as randomly getting selected I'm running
I'm gonna select one of the miners in
the system tell him you're the miner who
gets to update transactions choose the
transactions that are getting processed
now and they have discretion choosing
which transaction they want to only want
to process they get selected in
proportion to the to the mining power
and and the system selects one of those
at random in a process that can be
pretty well approximated as a Poisson
process so let me explain this together
with their next bullet to come so the
way that the system works or at least a
simplification can I've explained it is
that I'm gonna make all the miners
compete they're gonna waste some
resource in making some like census
computations all those sensitive
computations are kind of like drawing
lottery numbers and I just like the
difficulty level how hard it is to draw
a winning lottery number to make the
the average rate of somebody drawing a
lottery number of constant so on average
once every 10 minutes somebody draws a
lottery number
this person will get to mine a block
that's means like he gets to update the
legend project was processed a bunch of
transactions why once every 10 minutes
well I want to make sure that if
somebody mind a block will have enough
time to propagate to everybody else
before like the next person is selected
so 10 minutes is somewhat arbitrary but
like there are limits to how short or
Peggy can make this because I select one
miner at random it doesn't matter how
many miners there are the transaction
processing capacity of the system is
going to be constant if I double the
number of miners I don't get to process
any more transactions and this is a bit
of a weird property okay I had more
computers I don't get anything like any
more capacity out of them but think that
the big challenge here is that I have
many decentralized complete computers
they only need to be synchronized with
each other so in a sense like if I have
more computers in a network the
challenge is kind of bigger as well just
to make it a bit less weird so the
capacity how many transactions I can
process per unit time is independent of
how many miners I have again one is
selected at random and he can mine a
block the block the number of
transactions they can issue is also
limited again to make sure that it can
reach everybody else because this
process is random I have a lot of people
independently drawing lottery numbers
the total number the total arrival
process is going to be in a Poisson
rifle process on average a block arrives
every 10 minutes but it can be 5 or 15
it's a Poisson process at last I'm gonna
make an assumption that's a simplifying
assumption it's actually wrong but it's
I think the correct simplifying
assumption to make that miners can
freely enter an exit
so when you minor most of what he do is
actually trying to draw those lottery
numbers do those senseless computations
you just give you a chance of mining the
block you do a bit of other things like
checking the transactions validating
that everything is okay
collecting the memory but like the main
the main hurdle is like doing this
census computation that's equivalent you
look drawn a lottery numbers right now
in order to do this efficiently wanna
buy dedicated hardware so there's some
fixed cost if you want to start mining
and actually make profit out of it
there's some fixed cost I'm gonna ignore
that it's gonna allow me to state the
results more cleanly and elegantly and I
think that if you want to change our
results to allow for an entry cost a
fixed cost that that's a standard
exercise okay okay so let me write a
model and I guess you'll have to trust
me that like this is honest way to the
way that the system works but from now
on like we're just gonna analyze this
economic model and I don't need to worry
about too much about how Bitcoin works
otherwise okay so I'm gonna count the
number of miners by computing units
how many basic equivalent let's say we
have I'm gonna denote the total
computing power in the network by n and
I'm gonna assume that there are many
potential small - whose cost is cm so
there's a lot of people can buy
something that's ready off the shelf and
start mining at marginal cost of CM so
cm is the electricity cost when you're
mining you can turn on off a situation
yes
anything like I just assuming that the
there's a lot of people that can buy
things off the shelf or see em you can
have you can have a big miner in Iceland
that has a low cost in this you can have
a guy in China that has much lower cost
that can be not assuming anything else
about the other miners they could be big
miners I am assuming for entry and exit
especially of those small - I'm assuming
that - maximize profits and it's not on
the slide but I'm gonna assume that
they're honest the protocol works
there's a bunch of the bunch of issues
that I'm gonna obstruct away from
generally think of this as I'm assuming
that the system is functionally as
needed what's implied marketplace what
are the issues that left hole a
marketplace there's some disruptions
that miners can cause by bad behavior if
they're big enough double spending
attacks or something like that like I'm
ignoring all of those selfish mining
attacks if you want so as I said blocks
are edited post on rate I'm going to
denote the post on vector mu each block
in process K transactions in practice
transaction little different size but
I'm going to start away from that as
well if the blocks are edited Poisson
and Poisson rate mu and each one
processes K transaction the capacity of
the system the average number of
transaction the system can process per
unit time is K times meal what about the
users the users receive utility from
getting serviced so they get some
utility are from getting the service
they don't like waiting they have some
cost of waiting per unit time linear per
unit time for tractability W is how long
they have to wait until the transaction
is processed and B is how much they pay
in transaction fees and everything here
unless I say otherwise is in dollar
dollar units how much you should pay in
transaction fees should be counted as
dollars although you're gonna
denominator the payment itself is gonna
happen in Bitcoin but when I paint yen
in Japan I care about how much
I'm gonna assume that does the true
genius delay costs some people are at a
coffee shop and just want to leave
already so waiting for the transaction
to process is costly some people are
buying furniture online willingness to
pay can be either high or low with equal
probability again for simplicity for
this slide and I'm gonna assume it's
independent of the delay cost so some
people are buying drugs online some
people are buying drugs in person some
people are buying furniture online some
people are buying coughing person of
course you can include correlations here
this is all selected to make the model
as clean as possible and again another
assumption that makes the distinction
between Bitcoin and the monopolist is
clean and ice as possible is to assume
that the arrival rate of transactions
lambda is below the capacity of the
system so the system has excess capacity
okay so before I start analyzing what
bitcoin does let me start buying
benchmarking water fill module so if I
take profit maximizing film let's say
the film can process all the
transactions delay them as little or as
much as [ __ ] once it doesn't need to
use Bitcoin can use whatever it wants it
gets set prices and its cost of
processing transaction is zero and let's
suppose that half of our age is bigger
than RL that means that charging our age
and just charging the high willing to
pay customers is more popular than the
low ones very standard results like just
show that you can get monopoly
deadweight loss in the setting if I take
those customers and make them face
affirmed then the firm would not serve
the low willingness to pay customers and
users will not have any any surplus
and you can also say that if I have a
holdup problem because the firm will
respond to the value of users if the
value of users goes up suppose if they
get locked in then the firm will extract
all of that so just - is he right but
like in the model we have like a bit of
olive algebra just to show that the
problems that can occur in a monopolist
we can so now what would happen at a
Bitcoin and I think that this slide is
basically the biggest difference between
what happens under Bitcoin and under the
monopolist I said we have a bunch of
miners some of them may be big some of
them may have a cost advantage but I'm
assuming that the small ones enter
there's a lot of them and some of them
some of them enter and this is enough to
discipline all miners once you have some
of the small miners entering then no
miner can properly affect transaction
fees Oh in the service you can think of
all the miners as being a price takers
in this in the setting so have a
platform I have a service it's provided
by the miners and the miners
collectively cannot affect transaction
fees so why does it happen suppose I'm a
small minor if I'm a small minor I get
selected very rarely and then when I get
selected I can decide which transaction
to include or not and I can try to
threaten users or say you need to pay at
least two dollars a transaction
otherwise I won't include you but users
shouldn't really listen to me because I
get selected very rarely and even when I
do get selected well if I don't take the
transaction the next person will be so I
don't have much threatened users so
there's no reason why they should listen
to my threats and I should just take all
the transactions I can and not try to
convince users to change the transaction
fees
what'd I do if I'm a small minor I get
selected I get to see all the
transactions that are pending and I
process all the pending transactions
until like the lowest paying one doesn't
fit in my block I start from the highest
paying ones fill my block and once I get
the limit while I exclude the ones that
pay me the least I want to take the ones
that pay me more what happens if I'm a
big miner suppose I'm 30% of the mining
pool 30% of the mining pool I get
selected almost every third block if I
tell people if you don't pay a
transaction fee of $2 at least I'm not
gonna take you people will respond
because if you don't pay at least $2 it
means that you're gonna get delayed very
often so some people will raise this
reduction fees if I threaten them do not
process the rejection below $2 why would
that not be profitable for me as a large
miner well that's where the entry comes
in if I do that
Muse's starts baby more if users start
bidding more then there's more revenue
to be had and then moreover the small
miners will enter this entry by small
miners dilutes me and you can show by a
simple argument that like the dilution
will make it worse off always makes you
worse off so even if you're a large
miner because of the threat of entry by
small miners you want one effect paying
payments either even though you could
that make sense okay okay so we have
that all miners are price takers so that
means that the system is going to be
very simple from the - perspective if I
get selected I don't care if I'm small
or large I just take all the
transactions and I start from the
highest paying ones until I finish all
the transactions that are pending all
like I don't have any more space in the
block that means that all miners get the
same profit per unit the remaining unit
and that means that I can now calculate
pretty easily what is the number of
miners in the system
looking at the entry condition for the
small miners so the small miners until
until the break-even what's the revenue
per small minor well in total all the
miners get to shell in proportion to
their size the total revenue how much is
pay per unit time by users in form of
transaction fees plus I didn't mention
it but like there's another way of
rewarding the miners which is minting
new coin so every time you find a block
the system makes up new money and pays
it to you and that's the two form of
rewards that showed between the miners I
should say that the amount of money that
is mented by the system is denoted in
bitcoins cows and the number that the
miners should care about is the US
dollar equivalent cause the electricity
cost are in u.s. dollars therefore I
need an exchange rate here that's not
any place where I'm gonna talk about
this at the end
okay so that's the revenue per mining
unit just taking the total revenue
everybody is gonna share it in
proportion to the size that's the
revenue per mining unit small -
break-even so I get that this is the
number of miners in the system and you
can think of this as the system kind of
created a competitive platform of salts
will we procure mining power at the cost
of the marginal miner particularly if
all miners have exactly the same cost
all miners break even and the system
procures mining power it cost more than
that all the revenue that the system
raises goes to procure mining power and
in terms transforms to burning
electricity so as opposed to a firm all
the payments to the miners are getting
burned they're not transfers okay so now
the next question that they need to
answer is why would anybody pay here so
I told you that the miners have no
effect on how much users pay
what does determine how much users pay
[Music]
let me just say for a second skip this
slide but let me just like mention that
kind of ballpark the zero profit -
breakeven is doesn't seem crazy so we
took a paper that estimated mining
expenditures in profit in 2016 and of
course we don't expect - to literally
break even but ballpark it seems to be
right marginal miners break even the
guys in Iceland make a profit so how
much users paying transaction fees in
the model needs to decide first if we
wants to to participate or not if it's
worthwhile for them to use Bitcoin and
second if I'm participating how much
should I pay in transaction fees well I
want to decide how much up into a
section fee to trade off how much cost
we paid because of the injection fees
and how much cost I paid because
the delay and then it depends on my
delay cost how much I bid and the
distribution of how much other people
bid we said all the minors regardless of
the size are just going to process the
high span transactions so we can think
of how much up in transaction fees is my
priority relative to the other other
users if I pay a high transaction fee I
basically buy more priority so what we
want to think about now is a congestion
pricing game
well everybody competes full processing
for processing priority and note that in
this game I don't need to think about
the miners at all because the number of
miners did not affect the capacity of
the system and I know that all the
miners are gonna do the same thing some
of the perspective of users I don't need
to think about the miners at all there's
an implicit assumption that there's
enough - for the system to actually work
and be secure but except for that I
don't care so what is this object look
like ok so let me just show you a graph
yeah
well the important number to take in
mind here is like the general the
general statistics that you want to
think about in queueing system is the
congestion or the load of the system
which is the ratio between the demand
from common transactions to the capacity
of the system what percent of the
capacity of the system it needs to be
utilized on average what you're having
this graph here is how long is the delay
for somebody who doesn't pay anything
and gets the lowest priority if the
congestion is roughly below 1/2 even if
you don't pay anything you're gonna get
processed pretty quickly because like
blocks are very unlikely to be full and
therefore you gonna be in the next block
almost for sure when you get to 90%
capacity utilization then when averaged
is enough capacity for everything but
sometimes the block takes a bit longer
to arrive there's a backlog that builds
up there's not well over excess capacity
so
when a backlog builds up it takes it a
long time to clear so you gonna expect a
lot of delays in the system and at that
point like having priority will really
matter come so you get that users will
wanna pay more in transaction fees when
the system is close to a hundred percent
utilization because of the those delays
it would avoid otherwise there will be a
Hearst incentive to do so
okay we get a bunch of properties for
that let me just show you the graph
actually come so we solve this bidding
we find that this is essentially a
second price equivalent to a VC G
auction yeah well what you pay is the
externality the delay you impose on
others if the value of all users is high
enough everybody was willing to
participate and you can always just be
zero and just wait for a long time
everybody decides on the trade-off come
and what I think is very interesting in
this is how much you raise as a function
of the congestion so here's a plot that
comes out of MoMA of the model we need
to set a couple of parameters so what's
block size what a distribution of delay
cost come and then the only other
parameter that we need is what's the
role this utilization parameter so here
it ranges between zero and 100 percent
you can think of this is what percent of
the block size when the block size was
one megabyte what percent of the block
size was used if it's below half like
basically nobody pays as it approaches a
hundred percent utilization the payments
exploded come and let's lick compare
this to the data so now the blue points
each one day of data from the actual
Bitcoin blockchain
it stops when they adopted seg weight
which is a change that made some some
complications it makes it hard to
confirm but it's about the years of data
with varying congestion for each one of
the days we took
the horizontal act position over the
point I was on till access to be the
average block size so what percent of
the size of the blocks was used during
the day and the vertical is how much the
users paying transaction fees throughout
the day it converted to US dollars the
current according to the current
exchange rate and you can see that I
think that like the points have the same
features as line if you don't have
congestion nobody pays if you have
congestion two approaches one the
payments kind of explode and if you zoom
into this area
so I just assume to the right hand
corner you get that in this in this
position like this is actually a viable
payment scheme so you if you have like
80 percent utilization then some people
will pay to avoid the congestion the
point you divide the delays but you can
pay nothing and just wait for your
transaction and you get a system that
does not exclude anybody and yet managed
to raise money by pricing the wait for
those who are impatient and don't want
to wait for this is actually very
critical that we included their
stochasticity of the system you had a
deterministic block arrival time this
will not happen and I should say also
that the system did not collapse in this
region because the issue is of new coins
so miners are now mostly paid by new
coin in the long term it's gonna flip in
the long term they're gonna stare into
coin and then rely mostly solely on
transaction fees in the future this will
not be good for the system so this is a
big problem for the system if you think
of how volatile the payments are that's
one of the issues one of the I think
design flaws or one thing that the
system does not do correctly is that if
you look at the number of miners in the
system it depends on the revenue which I
just showed you
volatile depends on the congestion and
exchange rate
yeah it's also volatile none of those
things may indicate or need to indicate
need for more or less minors and when
there was a lot of congestion the system
people paid more miners and at the same
time we're complaining that people are
mining too much and too much money and
too much electricity is being spent on
mining so the the some imbalance here
something that's the marketplace design
here does not like correctly find the
right number of miners to have another
problem is that in order to raise
revenue I need to have congestion and I
told you that's like we're not gonna
exclude anybody we're gonna process all
the transactions assuming that I have
enough capacity and values are high
enough and we'll only go to price delays
but that means that if you don't you
don't pay you must incur some sort of
cost because if you don't incur some
cost when you when you don't pay nobody
would pay what is this cost you it's the
inefficiency of delay so some
transaction must be delays and both the
revenue that I get and the delay cost
that I get from the system are both
gonna be increasing with the congestion
if there's no congestion nobody pays and
nobody suffers delays as I increase the
congestion both of those will go up and
the delay cost is of course an
inefficiency of the system something
that you would like to avoid so you
asked about like can we do a different
design so under the current protocol the
block rate and block size are fixed and
there's a smart adjustment mechanism
that makes sure that if I double the
number - I still get a block every 10
minutes but it may not be the right
thing to do a block every 10 minutes
maybe wanna adjust those parameters
according to how much congestion you
have how much demand you have and just a
side note if you want to rely instead of
the block rewards the fixed number of
fees or like a fixed
transaction fee those are difficult to
because the system does not know that
change rate so if you set a transaction
fee of 0.1 Bitcoin that maybe $10 or
$10,000 depending the next change rate
so those things are tricky so what will
what we can suggest based on this kind
of pretty simple analysis you have a
market for delay here in the system
market for priority people value the
Purdy news dollars and it can elicit
from this marketplace a revenue that is
US dollars denominated come in the
current system you don't get stable
revenue because the congestion will
fluctuate but if we fix the congestion
at a stable level and the other
parameters the delay distribution the
delay costs remains fixed then we get a
stable revenue stream so we don't know
what the profit revenue stream is but at
least if you tell us what the stable
revenue stream we can get to a constant
one and the only thing we need is to
just target stable congestion and we can
do that by just adjusting the block size
of the block rate according to like what
we see on the demand from transaction is
and we can see on the on chain data so
like it's actually not a big change to
the protocol you can just look at the
data and say adjust the block arrival
rate or the box sorry so blocks are 80%
full is imposed by the miners which is
not due to condition
go mining gap so unless Simon Says pay
for electricity
I don't want to pay for electricity
until the fees are high enough so
suppose you're very very low demand I
would still wait and delay mining so
what I'm trying to do here is I'm gonna
adjust the block sizes so that was
always gonna be some congestion that
will make the fees at a constant level
so I try not to get in a situation where
I have those bad circumstances I try to
make sure that the system is in such a
state that mine that the users always
pay transaction fees so I don't run into
those other problems like yeah that's
okay so there's still a question of how
to set those parameters and basically
the analysis we do we do some stochastic
modeling and we get that the that
trade-off between revenue and delay cost
looks like this for every block sites so
think of the block size as having many
lanes in the same highway what do we
find is if the block size is about 20
you can basically approximate the
trade-off between revenue and delay cost
by scaling this child let me maybe show
it to you on this chart okay so here's
[Music]
here's a trade-off between revenue and
delay cost given different block sizes
so how to read this chart is fix the
block size starts from very high
transaction process in transaction
processing great come that means that
you're not gonna get any revenue from
anybody and you're not gonna deny
anybody so then you're gonna be in this
point zero come so and those under Luxus
have how much revenue erase from the
system and on the vertical axis I have a
how much delay cost I get from the
system
as I reduce my capacity I make the
arrival rate of the block slower then
both of those will increase I will
increase my revenue and I will increase
the delay cost and then I'm gonna travel
on one of those curves depending on my
block size so if I have a block size of
20 I make blocks less and less frequent
I start increasing revenue and delayed
cost and my gravity on delay cost both
increase and now the important feature
of all those charts is a the basically
vertical at zero come and they're all
kind of scaled version of each other
because the old scaled version of each
other and you really don't want to be
next to zero next to zero you get a lot
of delay cost and you get basically no
revenue for increasing this you'd rather
be in the follow away zone and that
basically makes it more efficient to try
to raise the revenue from congestion
when the block size is smaller the time
let me just so there's some technical
limits to that too but from this
perspective one may be better so I was
trying to tell you about comparing like
a monopolist front system with Bitcoin
and I want to say that Bitcoin has some
good things to offer I think that the
property that the miners that operate
the system basically have no control
over pricing is a very appealing
property but in many other ways the
system is defunct or suffers from some
inadequacies congestion pricing is I
think an interesting pricing mechanism
but it leads to valuable revenue and
there's nothing in the system that will
actually get us to the right amount of
mining
revenue that we want from users yeah so
that's what I want to say is like
summary slides I think there's much
we'll work to do I think this those
platforms should be thought as markets
or platforms that should really benefit
a lot from market design and will
encourage all of you to talk to the
other
[Applause]